todo
[Música]
hola hoy en saint clic el vacío
en términos generales al hablar de vacío
nos referimos a la ausencia de toda
materia visible se dice por ejemplo que
un vaso está vacío si no contiene ningún
líquido
pero en realidad desde un punto de vista
fundamental el vaso nunca está realmente
vacío por el contrario contiene un
número gigantesco de moléculas de aire
miles y miles de millones de moléculas
que constituyen un gas imperceptible a
primera vista pero que es una forma de
materia real y concreta
para realizar ciertos experimentos puede
ser conveniente quitar el aire de
nuestro entorno cuya presencia podría
ser problemática es lo que llamamos
crear un vacío
para conseguir este resultado es
necesario extraer todo el aire del
objeto que lo contiene
en la práctica resulta imposible
conseguir un vacío perfecto sin embargo
podemos acercarnos a ello gracias a las
técnicas modernas que permiten reducir
la cantidad de partículas miles de
millones de veces dicho esto el vacío
más extremo que puede obtenerse en un
laboratorio sigue estando muy alejado
del vacío absoluto
en el mejor de los casos quedan unos
cuantos miles de millones de partículas
por metro cúbico
si queremos encontrar un espacio aún más
vacío que lo que podemos crear en el
laboratorio es necesario salir de la
atmósfera terrestre y viajar al espacio
en el espacio que existe entre los
planetas en nuestro sistema solar por
ejemplo las partículas son muy escasas
solo podemos contar unas decenas de
millones por metro cúbico
es en el medio intergaláctico es decir
el espacio que existe entre las galaxias
donde nos encontramos con un vacío casi
total con un promedio de una sola
partícula por metro cúbico
con una densidad de materia tan pequeña
necesitaríamos un recipiente del tamaño
de nuestro planeta para tener tantas
partículas con un simple vaso
en un vacío perfecto con ausencia total
de materia ciertas propiedades que
consideramos evidentes dejan de serlo si
intentáramos tocar la guitarra en el
vacío no sería posible emitir ningún
sonido ya que la vibración de las
cuerdas no podría propagarse por el aire
hasta llegar a nuestros oídos por la
ausencia de cualquier forma de materia
capaz de restituir vibraciones el sonido
no puede viajar a través del vacío del
espacio
[Música]
asimismo en la superficie de la tierra
la atmósfera tiene un peso que empuja
hacia abajo los objetos que contienen
esto equivale a una cantidad colosal de
fuerza de compresión esta fuerza
corresponde al peso de doce elefantes
adultos por cada metro cuadrado
es lo que llamamos presión atmosférica
si nos sentimos esta presión en el día a
día es porque nuestro cuerpo y casi
todas las cosas de nuestro entorno
generan también una presión interna
dirigida hacia el exterior que compensa
perfectamente la presión atmosférica
consideremos una botella de plástico en
la que creamos un vacío al extraer el
aire que contiene
ahora que está vacía la botella ya no
puede resistir la presión exterior
porque ya no tiene contenido por lo
tanto se comprimirá violentamente por el
peso de la atmósfera
por último un espacio vacío no posee
realmente una temperatura en realidad lo
que llamamos temperatura es el grado de
agitación de las partículas en un
determinado entorno en el aire por
ejemplo es más caliente cuando las
moléculas de aire que están más agitadas
y más frío cuando lo están menos
pero en un espacio vacío por la ausencia
de partículas es imposible medir
cualquier nivel de agitación
por lo tanto el concepto de temperatura
pierde su significado
en el vacío el calor solo puede
propagarse a través de la luz y otras
ondas electromagnéticas que son las
únicas capaces de viajar en el vacío
pensemos ahora en la idea del vacío no a
escala humana sino a escala microscópica
toda la materia está formada por átomos
un átomo está formado por un núcleo
alrededor del cual orbitan los
electrones el núcleo es unas 100.000
veces más pequeño que el átomo conjunto
pero representa por sí mismo el 99.9 por
ciento de la masa total del átomo los
átomos están formados en su mayor parte
por vacío lo que significa que toda la
materia visible en el universo también
está hecha de vacío
en conclusión aún más vacío de los
espacios nunca estará perfectamente
vacío según la física moderna el vacío
cuántico es un estado constantemente
ocupado por una gran cantidad de
partículas virtuales que aparecen y
desaparecen continuamente estas son
conocidas como fluctuaciones del vacío
una partícula virtual es una partícula
cuya existencia es tan efímera que
resulta imposible observarla
las leyes de la mecánica cuántica dicen
que es posible que tales partículas
aparezcan de la nada a condición de que
desaparezcan muy rápidamente de modo que
sea imposible observarlas
como las partículas virtuales no pueden
ser observadas se permite que posean
algunas propiedades muy extrañas
por ejemplo el hecho de que puedan
aparecer de la nada o que algunas puedan
tener una energía negativa
aunque es imposible observarlas la
existencia de estas partículas virtuales
provoca algunos fenómenos concretos y
medibles
estas partículas son las portadoras de
las cuatro interacciones fundamentales
de nuestro universo
por ejemplo el intercambio de fotones
virtuales permite que las cargas
eléctricas interactúen a distancia
estas partículas también tienen efectos
indirectos como el hecho de que ejerce
una cierta presión sobre los objetos
también intervienen en lo que se conoce
como radiación de hawking cuando los
agujeros negros se evaporan con el
tiempo como resultado de su fuerte
atracción gravitatoria que convierte las
partículas virtuales en ordinarias
hoy en día pensamos que la energía
cuántica contenida en el vacío podría
ser muy similar a la energía oscura un
importante y desconocido tipo de energía
que tiende a acelerar la expansión de
nuestro universo
sin embargo cuando comparamos su
intensidad con la de la energía oscura
nos encontramos con un número que es
10.000 millones de google es de veces
mayor este es uno de los mayores
misterios sin resolver de la ciencia
moderna lo que se conoce como la
catástrofe del vacío
[Música]